voir lie au comptoir je suis bien
jacques duval bonsoir en ligne a fait un
disque absolument formidable on va faire
comme à la télé ils te sorti un disque
qui s'appelle cancon qui est absolument
extraordinaire avec une pochette génial
d'hugo pratt et a amené duval qu'est le
parolier et qui a quand même les pattes
assez longue et elano et là il à
l'anneau mâle teddy un côté du mauvais
côté la suite tout retard ou alors tu
fais du handi de toi que tu es enfin le
dit et quand on écoute le disque on en
est persuadé tuer le le digne successeur
de serge gainsbourg pour faire sonner la
langue française il y en a qui veulent
d'étudier moi je dis vive
qu'est-ce qui a fait la musique des
enfants et 4g comme l'a dit voir le jour
ouais et le grand yannick grand ian
baker mais un conte vincent palmer à
l'image de ces géniales et la mode alors
à la mode c'est de l'argent avec ça au
moins et je gagne de l'argent avec ça au
moins que tu entends pas
du fond de mon entraîneur de me
justifier d'un puits s'est produit alors
pourquoi non c'est pas parce que tu
daignes en ahl c'est ou non c'était ce
que j'ai dis du mal à dessiner des robes
j'espère que tu gagnes de l'argent au
moins plus de ton travail de chanteuse
mais donne du mal à faire de la mode
j'espère que tu gagnes de l'argent dans
la vie en lui aulas et 6 à 10 ans la
croix tu te dis penly aulas je m'habille
en bio mais hors de ton émission
abondent dans mon émission tu sais que
j'ai un pote de christian lacroix dont
tu t'habilles on est mal faite pour ça
bah oui mais du même pays c'est pour ça
et a6 alors dit moi rien
ouais j'avais épousé c'est ce à quoi le
chien d'abord je demande une idole assez
rondelette franchement quoi stresser du
jour d'un état qu'ils n'ont pas droit au
chômage alors tais toi tu es connu
beaucoup cherché mais elle n'est pas
baptisé là elle n'est pas baptisé tu
sexuellement avant d'en faire m'écoute
je pense qu'elle sera beaucoup de bien
aux diables rouges est d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien le rencontrer et donc je
trouve cela très bien de matière et en
enfer à l'école quand même temps elle
n'ira peut-être pas d'école peut-être
bien mais cette passe à dix pendant 24
ans ainsi lancé pas ça mais parce que
j'ai la technique d'une centaine c'est
pas une histoire de location mais j'ai
dit que c'est bon que la fesco baptisé
encore se seront pas mais tu l'envoies
pas l'école chez job mais j'ai quand
même plus grave dans des caisses à
l'époque de sa bâtisse
je veux dire le tolérer j'attends les
liens